hi my name is Eugene Tong I'm the style
director at details magazine and today
on new classics we'll be talking about
watches one of the biggest trends of the
last few years for men's watches is the
all-black trend and today I'm going to
show you some of the latest and greatest
the all-black trend has been applied to
watches across the board so you'll see
some that are more dressy and some that
are more sporty there is a sporty-er
watch from the brand Tudor this one is a
chronograph as well as this rubber strap
which makes it perfect for any type of
casual occasion I wouldn't recommend
wearing this under suit necessarily but
then again watches your personality and
you can kind of do what you want but I
don't think you should we're seeing a
lot of guys switch out their traditional
bracelet straps with a new NATO strap
that has become so popular for example
this one from Alpena has a great canvas
strap but is back on leather so you know
that it's going to last as well here's
another great option from Yubel the mesh
bracelet was a huge trend back in the
day and it's coming back in a big way
this year however the newly designed
ones are much more comfortable on the
wrist and won't catch your hair or your
skin like the old ones used to another
great option is this tag watch
it's a coronagraph but this one has a
bit of a textured sporty band and that
makes it a little bit more casual and
kind of adds a little bit of masculinity
another one on the higher-end scale is
this Panerai probably one of the first
to come out with oversized is a great
option for the guy who has like a more
athletic or larger wrist the oversize
trend is still huge within the men's
watch market for me I think it's about
complementing your wrist so if you have
a smaller wrist I think you should go
with the smaller watch if you have a
larger wrist and I think over size
really works within the all-black trend
you see some companies doing more shiny
and some doing more matte for example
this one from rato is a really great
matte finish on the watch so you can get
into your matte black car and have your
matte black watch to match a lot of
watch companies have started to apply
this all black trends they're classic
watches for example this one from Lovato
this is their classic day tron front of
Graf with the application of the
all-black trend which i think makes it
really modern chic as well as super
masks
even the lower pricepoint companies have
started embracing this trend for example
this one from Nick cents one hundred and
fifty dollars and you can't get anything
better for this value while still
staying on trend I think all black
watches are timeless and a great
addition to any man's watch collection